and we're alive and welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel and a very
exciting episode because we get to talk
Sidetrack and okay it's not quite
official
but it's near as damn it okay if I can
hear myself oh that's going to annoy me
I had to make sure it was on mute I was
fingers crossed it didn't tell me or not
I was like come on come on
but we have exciting news because we
look like we're
nearest damn it there so
welcome to sidetrack
[Music]
I have had a couple of
um
negative number messages saying that
this is nothing news this is just
deadline talking about Stargate weather
there
the reason why are we we're right hello
guys
there is a reason why this story
yesterday or Friday from deadline is so
exciting and we'll talk about in a
second but hi guys how are you
doing well good I might feel right good
good so first of all when you saw this
news and the little video I did
yesterday what was your first thoughts
before we get into actually what it
means
my first well quick jump online show
friends and get an article that
literally I was trying to get this
article out and it would the website
would not load I thought it was broken I
was I was
I was stressing but we finally got it
out
yeah but yeah trying to beat gateworld
and we beat them on everything else but
they beat us on that
um
actually seeing the reactors actually
seeing someone else talk about it
like someone
I said this on Tech talk for lack of a
better word proper journalists
yeah like talking about it
amateur at best so yeah it was good
how about you Harris
I was I was bumped about it uh
you know I I kind of like that
miniseries into maybe a movie into a
television series idea
but I wouldn't mind a movie into a a
television series either or a television
series into a movie either one because
obviously Star Wars you know talking a
little bit about Star Wars just a minute
ago but they just announced that they're
going to be doing a culmination movie of
the Mandalorian and I kind of think
that's a good idea just kind of get some
traction moving and then
an end goal
so I think it's good
there is a reason why
um it's so
important that this is the story for one
this is the kind of the story
we were told or I was told because there
is somebody that works in marketing for
one of the the larger marketing firms in
Hollywood that I do get to speak to and
they have done work for Paramount MGM
and a couple of others and they told me
just before this gets announced expect
to see lots of reports lots of Articles
and stuff on lots of different places
um and we've seen that over the last few
months we've seen these lots of um game
Rants and Screen Rants and all these
other people they just talk about
Stargate all of a sudden
um but deadline talking about it is a
bit different because that is that is
that deadline and not talking about a
rumor they have spoken to people at
Amazon and this is what Amazon have told
them to say
um and it's it's a little
um
teasy they're teasing us there's not a
lot of detail in this
um story because
you know they Amazon don't want a lot of
detail and they haven't made their minds
up which we're going to talk about in a
minute on a couple of big points of this
but this is this is immediate this is
somebody this is the marketing
department at Amazon speaking to a
reporter deadline we want this story out
we're going to be doing this this and
this we're going to be doing I mean
we're talking about Stargate and we've
forgotten we're forgetting that Legally
Blonde is getting a movie and a TV
series guys yeah I mean that blew my
fragile little freaking mind I'm like a
series of Legally Blonde and we were the
spirit's going to be in it
is she really yeah probably no
um so I mean that she might blow my
brains out I've seen Legally Blonde I
didn't like it
I have seen it yeah I like the first one
it was all right but like
[Music]
um
um I have got a rumor about um 2001 A
Space Odyssey they were gonna they
apparently they've been trying to work
on doing a
um streaming
um mini series based on the original
book instead of a movie because I've
always said that that they wanted sort
of like something like six hours
to really take advantage of the movie
and that didn't get the original
original book by our first C Clarke or
the original book by
um I think it'll be the original but
then the Stanley Kubrick was the he
worked with Arthur C Clarke to make a
screenplay I think something like that
so it'll be based on the book rather
than the screenplay but um so that's you
know that that's the thing it's
apparently though they've been working
on this for six months and then somebody
pointed out that they don't actually
have the TV rights so
six months
they went as far as like like who could
start yeah somebody's in the background
going doing rights to that
they don't so but that doesn't mean it's
um off it just means it's going to be
delayed because they're going to go and
renegotiate the screen right okay so
anyway
yeah yeah
um it's just just a legal issue but now
um but anyway going back to Stargate
this I'd say this isn't this this is as
good as an official announcement as you
can get until we get to Comic-Con San
Diego
um in July when we're going to get the
actual
people on a stage talking about it
the thing I liked most about this is
if they do if they do what they did with
Kenobi but they bring Richard Dean
Anderson on stage and they say to him
are you gonna believe Jack O'Neill again
and he goes yes I am oh
we will lose that fragile I'm really
serious about thinking about getting a
ticket to San Diego
I'm seriously I'm like how do I get in
yeah come on that's too late no no man I
don't think I can get tickets but I'm
gonna um for the actual Comic-Con but
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna look into
it now because it's just
Jenny stiven is here hello Jenny
foreign get well soon Jenny she's got a
little bit of a pooriness at the moment
but
um it's just yeah it's it's absolutely
brilliant actually Jenny
um she I got a bit nervous about this
about two weeks ago and I even said to
Jenny um
I think this is going to be next year
I think I'm starting to really Panic
that this it just feels more a couple of
my sources are telling me don't worry
it's happening it's happening One Source
was saying like oh if it's not announced
really soon mate then you know forget
about it
um he actually said if it's not ready by
Comic-Con forget about it it'll be next
year and I was like oh god
um and Jenny's like no don't worry don't
worry you're all right
and then so she would rejuvenated
who used to work at MGM theater guys
don't know so get in the comments and
throw questions no don't don't give me
um but yeah hopefully we'll get on a
live at some point and she'll come and
join us
um but anyway when she but she's a very
busy lady
when they do the Comic-Con at San Diego
there and they've got to announce this
they need actors on the stage don't they
they do
the biggest thing is and the biggest
rumor is that Amanda Tapping and Michael
Shanks have already been approached
about this I've heard that rumor three
times
RDA
we know that was sort of planned when
you know
a certain company that shall not be
maimed because people will go crazy and
get angry and we're you know maybe
pitching an idea that they would like
Richard Dean Anderson to come back as
O'Neill we all generally hated the idea
I quite like it could kill him off so
they could kill him off
um but I mean would that be for me the
way to announce this
you bring Amanda Tapping on a Michael
Shanks and you talk about you announce
it
we're in we're doing this and then
halfway through
you bring what you doing and then he
beams into the he beams into Comic-Con
that would be cool
just bring him through like the floor
and then he walks in like because it's
all smoke and all crap like that yeah
that could happen
if you're listening do it that's that's
the way to do it from Amazon for 18
months now mate we've been telling
Amazon how to do this
and uh now just we're even helping them
announce it should we get salaried from
Amazon
writer's room you know
I'm pretty sure at this point I deserve
an executive producer but I came out of
work I put into this but
I just I just tell you guys what I get
told I actually don't put that much work
into it but
um
no credit at all uh even though during
their story completion they were asking
if they were saying it was there it was
down to them so I figure Robert was
saying like we because of our
um hard work and it's got
um Stargate is trending on Twitter and
we're gonna get oh my God
how are you taking credit for this
anyway
um
I I gotta say I think that's the way to
do it you know you know we heard the
rumor about
um six or seven months ago that they
were apparently talking to miles to
teller I've been told that's crap
they've decided they're not going a
movie star at all
they're not going that way
um
yeah they just need to get the costs
they're they are genuinely thinking
about costs apparently
um so I do wonder if they have got half
an eye on like like what we said if they
do a movie and it bombs it kills the
franchise
but if they do a movie and they don't it
don't spend an absolute Fortune and it
just does okay
they're all right you know
Jillian whoop
um you know I think but I I
don't know what do you think one thing I
thought about recently was the card
season three has been so massively
popular I know you guys not big trekkies
but Picard season three has been so
massively popular and that retro sort of
like throwback to you know remember Star
Trek next Generation is 30 years old
Stargate sg1 is coming to its 30th
anniversary
it's shown that actually us all sci-fi
Geeks will watch us and go crazy and it
can still attract a new audience I I
wonder if that might have actually given
mgmn and Amazon a little bit more
confidence to do this what do you guys
think about it
probably looking at if you see something
that is on the same sort of scale and it
performs well they're going to have
they're gonna have a renewed confidence
in it for sure
I mean just think about Legacy kind of
things
sci-fi I feel like really large Legacy
things kind of started around that kind
of Star Wars force awakens time I always
gotta rope it back to Star Wars of
course but around that same time Disney
was doing jungle book The Lion King
Cinderella all these different remakes
reboots etc etc and of course Force
awakens is the most successful domestic
U.S film ever and it's just made a an
exuberant amount of money there so a lot
of people been
remake and reboot and etc etc and they
haven't really been all that great until
we got Top Gun and
if you can kind of have a little fighter
pilot kind of aspect to it which
Stargate tends to have
plus the Legacy people stuff liking
things in sci-fi that was awful grammar
right there by the way but Star Trek
Legacy stuff Star Wars legacy stuff like
they just announced a another sequel
movie of course and that's 15 years in
the future we'll get into a different
discussion about that a different day of
course but uh there's a lot of Legacy
things going on both in military movies
and Sci-Fi movies and those tend to be
the best Legacy thing so why wouldn't
they in in a lot of ways you know
by the way before I forget I need you
guys to get into the comments the
regular side trackers particularly I'm
going to do I'm going to really remove
the bring back Stargate hashtag bring
back Stargate to YouTube and I'm going
to put a
Stargate is back basically t-shirt but
do I do
Stargate is back the gate is open or
seventh chevron's locked so those are
the three sort of designs I'm thinking
about
you guys tell me in the comments which
one do you want to see on this web on
the website and then I will get that
designed and put that on for this week
at some point I wanted to do it before
today but I didn't have time
um but
so yeah so yeah seven Chevrons locked
the gate is open Stargate returns which
ones you want
um
the thing I loved on the
um on the
on this deadline because on this
deadline report as well they said it was
going to be probably a movie first
which again just went to me when
yeah that's what we've been saying
um so I love that thing but it just it
just does that does that tell us
basically that what we've been saying is
exactly right that it looks like
Jennifer salkey wants to do a movie
because there's this big chunk of money
that Amazon have said look here's a
money here's a money make seven movies a
year and Jenny's going while Stargate
can be one that perfect we've got the
money already put aside we've already
got the budget for it
um
but other people Michael Wright other
people like this prohibited MGM plus is
saying no it's this this makes sense for
a movies for one great that they've
they've you know confirmed that really
with deadline but what do you guys think
do you think do we need to really be
shouting no come on we want a series we
don't want a movie or do we not really
care
it depends on the price point they're
going for because if they're not gonna
take that big of a risk and try to spend
a whole bunch of money on a movie
they might be able to do all right you
know uh one way or another and and it
could be a fun jumping back onto point
if they do it correctly
that's a big if big if but it could be
good
yeah at the moment seven chevron's
locked even though a couple of people
have said no it's nine Chevrons but um
I've got another idea for you for your
T-shirt what about just Kush
because that is the gate opening kawush
okay that might that might people might
need to explain that so yeah but if you
know
it's okay
um
movie probably
I think this has got to be announced by
it's to July basically that's the one
we're doing now they've announced it now
virtually but would you like they've got
to make a decision and we'll talk about
what's holding up that decision in a sec
but
um what do you think man it's
probably is that a big I mean that
really stands out in the article it's
probably a movie yeah I think it's been
we've always thought a TV show is going
to come first but there's been too many
too many hurdles I I guess leading up to
this point
regarding whether it's going to be a
movie or TV show and Jennifer's Augie
really wants a movie I think she's going
to get away
she's the boss yeah and so someone on
Tick Tock commented on one of our videos
um
always going to be a reboot whatever
and I was basically saying the plan was
always going to be to make a franchise
and we're going to do it they were we
always thought it was gonna be a TV show
but
if they do a movie maybe it may it might
not actually be that bad
because there has been ten well now it's
like nearly 12 years since the gate
closed essentially uh 2011 so by the
time it comes out it'll be 2024 so about
12 years 13 years something like that
um they're gonna need something
fresh they can't I I I would love them
to just continue the TV show
but because so long so much time has
passed I think
now I've had like quite a while to think
about the fact that we're getting a
movie because we've known about it for a
while
it probably would be the best the best
way to do it because you bring in more
people a fresher audiences but you'll be
able to go back to
um what what we already knew and finish
and close those stories off
Wuzzles are bringing in a new a new
storyline for the TV show and the
franchise moving forward
I don't think we have to worry about
them not closing things like Stargate
Universe off I think they will I just
don't think they have to do it straight
away
I've always thought I could wait they
could wait a while and it could it could
be like a they could have multiple story
arcs going on
throughout the movie that will never get
closed after
um like so it's kind of like what they
do with Marvel films like they hint at
things that don't happen for like movies
and movies later on
um down the line they could they could
Hint it and then have it actually have a
pan out later on that could definitely
happen
and as we said on
Sidetrack first it doesn't look like
Mark Fergus and his team at penguin and
Parker are going to be getting this
um I've got a video coming up tomorrow
talking about the production companies
that may or may not be involved in this
and that I I do think that's one of the
another big reason why we're holding up
on a movie or a TV series from what I'm
hearing there's a couple of companies
that are sort of vying to try to be the
production partner
and one of them really wants to push
forward with a series and think that's
what that's that's what they're
recommending they're like saying let's
do a series and the other Brooklyn
companies go now let's do a movie and
Jennifer salkey is there going we've got
this budget for a movie and but like I
said then there's other voices in them
Jim
I can't believe though that that deal
isn't really virtually done if we're
getting an announcement in July I I
should imagine that's
their negotiating those are the final
things but but I don't want to talk
about it too much because I've got the
video tomorrow and I think it'll make
more sense when you watch the video
tomorrow but um I would imagine if we've
had this this deadline articles they
would have made a decision by now they
know what they're doing
yeah it's just a matter of a matter of
them announcing it or someone we know
telling us
yeah but but the thing they're saying
probably a movie I think does scream
that actually they might not have made
that final decision
um I think that I think they're possibly
negotiating
with a couple of companies to try to
figure out what it is exactly they want
to do and the fact that Amazon have said
it's probably going to be a movie May
mean that they've kind of
they have decided
but it's not signed
yeah I think it probably leans more to
they they want to do a movie that's
that's final they're going to do a movie
it's who they're going to do it with
yeah
and um and they just they just I think
they've thrown that word in just in case
things break down and they they flip and
go the other way
sort of thing
um so they don't look stupid we said
probably a movie we didn't say
definitely so um
they've got to be careful with how they
say things now because Stargate fans
have been burnt before with the trilogy
movie that was announced green lit and
now and and it was in the works and
everything like that that never happened
like
that I was so stressed I know I know it
wasn't it wasn't a great idea
but we were still excited as Stargate
fans to finally get more Stargate and
then it never happened and what six
seven years later we're here talking
about oh it's coming back again and we
don't want to get burnt again
and Jenny's got it from there that it's
about the distribution as well and you
need that partnership deal in place so
you can maximize and it's about money
it's about maximizing the money it's
about minimizing risk for MGM and Amazon
that's why they want to spread the the
risk around a little bit like having
production companies involved and then
maximizing profits afterwards and and
but getting again with Amazon we keep
talking on this they don't own Studios
they don't own Studio space so they need
to produce something with
you look at anything Amazon's done ever
it's always in production with somebody
else
another Studio another thing
um
well
worth minimizing production uh cost and
distribution costs Etc et cetera keeping
it like kind of on the same team and
stuff why not just take it it's not the
perfect idea or a perfect idea but why
not take like maybe the first pilot
episode or the First Act of whatever the
series they're writing and translate it
into a film
yeah would that be the worst idea in the
world kind of keep it in fergus's hands
uh otspie's hands and kind of allow them
to streamline it kind of start off in
the second Arc for a pilot instead but
see I don't know why they just haven't
done a streaming I I think we keep
hearing is going to be a cinematic
release that's what we keep hearing and
I'm exciting and what I stole this
because it's they've got the money sat
there ready so I think that's the
budget's already been agreed a billion
something pound a year
um
but I don't understand why if they're
worried about the and the voices at MGM
are saying well if this bombs and this
is what this is what we keep saying if
it bombs it kills the franchise dead
yeah so do a streaming movie half the
budget
you've got none of the like advertising
costs and distribution costs and all
that you just put it on Amazon Prime
and if you get decent numbers well you
don't really care if you get decent
numbers or not because really it's just
a two-hour advert for the franchise yeah
just do that don't don't complicate it
but saying that is there any better way
and I know it's a different world we
live in today than maybe 10 years ago
but is there any better way to announce
a big franchise and to really stamp on
things saying we're behind this than a
cinematic release
it shows a lot of confidence if they're
going to do Cinema
streaming I think is a bit of a cop-out
um it's it's kind of what they do if
they don't have that much confidence
it's going to do well sort of slap it
onto stream because they'll know I get
views because people are already paying
for the subscription
but it's if they stick it in cinema if
they didn't stick it in cinemas because
they don't believe people are going to
buy tickets to go and watch you if they
are thinking of doing that they think
they're going to get the ticket sales so
it shows a lot of confidence
yeah
um Emily's just made the point now that
will it be I hear it's going to be in
Canon but I have heard sort of rumors
and what we've seen in shows recently is
that it's going to be sort of I think we
called it a hybrid cannon that they that
they will pick and choose there'll be
certain things about Canon they will be
allowed to sort of ignore
um but we've seen that with even Picard
season three and Picard coming back and
start and the new Trek that they did
this they sort of they they didn't
really they ignored certain bits they
didn't want if they complicated the new
show but to be honest any new show does
that there even even well Stargate was
really always really good with them
Canon but even in Star Trek when they
did a new story if it messed with Canon
they just ignored it they just say hello
everybody and I think that's what we're
gonna I'm here and this is going to MGM
plus but I understand that's not
necessarily decided but to go to MGM
plus but what you have to remember is
Amazon then has things like freebie so
what they could very easily do is put
this on MGM Plus without adverts 4D 4K
4D 4K you know all that and then put it
on something like free V you know six
months later with adverts
maybe a lower resolution something like
that you know um so I think it won't
matter if you if you're willing to be
patient you'll get to see it
um because we've got all these
distribution channels they they they can
get it out to as many people as they
really need to
yeah
in some capacity whether you have to pay
199 for it or 249 or whatever it is
I mean I'm really not opposed to MGM
plus but I just much rather run Prime I
I if they wanted to be successful I
don't see why they wouldn't put it on
prime it just doesn't make any sense to
me besides promoting MGM plus but why
promote MGM plus when you have Prime and
freebie as well it's just I think it's
in America MGM plus is more of a
Channeler isn't it it is a
it's a relatively big streaming Channel
already that's the point internationally
it's not I don't think it is here either
I don't know a single soul that I I have
every single I I mean I even on Amazon
Prime I pay for shutter I I have like a
couple other little small things
curiosity stream brilliant things like
that but I don't I don't have MGM plus
so I have all of those channels you just
mentioned sound like adult related
content
shutter is a [__] it's horror stuff
it's a bunch of scary stuff it's great
it's all horror I thought you said
horror I was like oh it is
who knows you know
we don't have that here so um
we have curiosity and Brilliant though
but they're they're um they're mostly
just web apps because a lot of YouTubers
constantly you know advertise them
it's not a thing in America either so
but I think
Amazon want it to be I think that's the
problem okay
um the the from what I've been told and
it does make 100 sense is that Amazon
are trying and they don't Amazon don't
want Amazon Prime to be a streaming
Channel per se they want it to be a hub
of streaming channels so they want you
to have Amazon Prime but then you have
your add-ons that you want so you have
MGM plus if you want that you have you
know you've got freezy anyway but they
wanted and that's where you go to watch
Disney it's where you go to watch
you know
um Nickelodeon whatever it's where you
go to watch other streaming services so
they want
it to go on MGM and the only way you're
going to get people to watch MGM plus is
if you put shows on there that people
want to watch
you know it's but the the biggest
problem I have is there are too many
streaming services
and they're already spending way too
much money
they're desperately trying to cut
content already but they're gonna have
to see some of these channels managing
they're gonna have to I think the best
option for them to do would be even if
it's just the first season whack that on
Prime because you want it to have the
most reach possible Jenny's just
mentioned it here unfortunately MGM plus
would not have the reach enough like
imagine the budget if they put it on MGM
Plus
it will be limited yeah there's no other
way to do it but more people would see
it
yeah
well
like you just said there's too many
streaming services Amazon having three
of them
one hope to rule them all yeah that's
what they want gone sorry house no no
I'm just saying that's just too many I
mean freebies already technically part
of Amazon Prime because you can access a
lot of freebie from there so why not
just make it MGM Prime
or something like that you know Amazon
Prime is still Prime as part of Amazon
it's pretty synonymous with the name by
this point you don't need Amazon on
there and you can have it on the front
page anywhere MGM Prime brought to you
by Amazon you know it'll still sound
better than HBO's new freaking name Max
the place to watch them or whatever it
is come on come on you know we didn't
get that because HBO has been around so
long and it's such a big thing I would
have dropped the max yeah just go back
to HBO now or something I I don't know I
didn't get that
um
but yeah I mean I I I'm hoping that's
not what they do but I've heard that a
couple of times that they want this to
go on MGM plus so Michael Wright is head
of MGM plus and he's everything and he's
the biggest proponent to get this out
and but the whole reason and they still
got to remember the whole reason why
Amazon bought MGM is for MGM
intellectual properties it's things like
Stargate robocopter
why do that if you're not then going to
push the MGM Plus
Channel
and the only way to push it like I say
is to put content on it people want to
watch
but you know Disney have been spending
an absolute bloody Fortune 500 million
dollars losing 500 million dollars a
quarter at one point because they were
just plowing content onto Disney plus
they bought Fox they didn't create a fox
plus Network they didn't they they put
it on Disney plus yeah or Hulu that's
that's what that's that's one thing I
don't understand why they don't just do
with MGM plus they own the company now
they own the intellectual properties why
don't they just whack it all on why do
you need a separate channel for MGM
content it's your company you own the
entire thing it's just Prime it's just
Prime content as far as I'm concerned
it's Amazon content
you know remember the company's merged
but yeah it's a little bit more
complicated than that but yeah basically
yeah any any project moving forward is
going to be an Amazon MGM product yeah
whack it on Prime
the one bonus thing is you just buy MGM
Plus for a month watch smash through it
and then
um that yeah you're done and this is
this is what the genius do is basically
green was uh the strategy to become an
aggregator of sub streaming services and
that's what I'm saying it's a hub it's
the place you go to watch other things
so that's the long term plan I think
that's going to come that's going to
come along the bottom in the ass at some
point if they want to do that they
should start doing that right now
because HBO HBO Max I guess at the
moment and and Disney plus they're
they're great little hubs because you go
to Disney plus you say Okay I want my
Marvel I want my Star Wars I want my
National Geographic I want my hot stars
or whatever uh the international version
of everything is
your Fox stuff 20th centuries there you
go to HBO you can pick oh I want my
Cartoon Network oh I want my DC stuff oh
I want uh Harry Potter themed things
Amazon I love Prime I think Prime
actually is coming out with arguably the
best TV shows in the next two or three
years it's insane the only company that
can compete with them is HBO with like
Game of Thrones kind of stuff with the
quality of shows
but that being said Prime has the pardon
my French but the shittiest like
operating system to actually go inside
and use the use the app it's so bad and
just make it a hub put MGM plus as an
option on Amazon Prime put shutter as an
option on Amazon Prime put such and such
whatever as an option on Amazon Prime
and you can scale that over time to just
to correct Disney doesn't actually fully
own Hulu and they own a third of Hulu I
believe
um is it CBS I think it's Universal
Universal owns the rest and they don't
have them Disney is supposed to buy Hulu
this year for like 30 billion or
something ridiculous
um and bought Disney are arguing at the
moment going it's not worth that because
but you said it was two years ago
because yes but two years was a very
long time ago Hulu's not worth 30
billion anymore so they're trying to
negotiate at the moment but Disney don't
actually own Hulu outright yet I would
be very surprised if Hulu didn't just
merge with Disney plus once they do own
it I think they'll just merge it which
is one of the reasons why they're trying
to get out well I I don't I don't think
Disney's trying to buy it I think
they're trying to sell it to Universal
and that's why they keep upping the
price as they try to like oh yeah Hulu
is worth this
agreement in place for Disney to buy it
contractually they're supposed to buy it
this year oh okay it was agreed like two
years ago
um but Disney are a threatening
statement of court because they want to
pay less they see they're saying it's
not valued the value is too much now
Street the whole world has changed in
the last two years streaming services
that numbers are way down it's not worth
that anymore
um
but but yes let's see what happens with
that it's interesting
um Disney owns 60 people sorry that's
right it's two-thirds and they they have
to buy the last third that's correct I
think that's right
um but so
wherever we do get to see it eventually
I just hope that they do actually put
through a decent budget and they
actually do the movie but I do think
that possibly the budget on the series
will depend on how the movie does but
we've always said and and everything
I've ever heard and I think Jenny will
agree with this in a second there that
um they've always said this is going to
be uh a big Cornerstone project for them
the Amazon this is going to be their
Star Trek this is going to be their Star
Wars this is going to be now this is
that's how they see this and and don't
just wondering what you guys think about
I I've always thought that Stargate
can't compete with Star Trek I think
it's just as good I'm supposed to
actually think it's better
um and particularly the new crack is a
bit hit and miss
do you guys think that Stargate can
actually become and get in the comments
guys tell us what you think as well can
Stargate be up there with Star Wars Star
Trek you know some of the best sci-fi
and most watched sci-fi franchises
on anyway
that was the best science fiction show
of all time
other than Firefly we've agreed that
fireflies
very good but Stargate is the daddy
Stargate another one uh Stargate is is
just as good if not better than any
other Sci-Fi show I still haven't
watched the Firefly don't crucify me I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get there uh
you need to watch it I know I I didn't
say anything
you need to watch it
he's always on the border edge of
getting cut thrown out anyway because
he's American and he's got better facial
hair than me but I mean just
and magnificent mugs
I do love his mugs
I was very happy
dude watch Firefly honestly there's only
14 episodes it won't take very long
you've got to watch firefight it's the
most in my video I said 12 episodes
yeah there's 12 episodes no there's 14.
I was very surprisedly surprised
[Laughter]
it's amazing
um only Joel for showing on telly though
so that's maybe maybe that's what you're
thinking
the guys in the comments though have
been talking
um all this Jenny said something else
just a second everyone else I don't
think good news yeah it could be if kind
of goes into a production deal with you
for instance I think becomes a major
creative play with students that was a
that was a response to is Amazon is
YouTube charging blah blah blah a good
sign four star game
yeah
um yeah potentially but again it's it's
all to do with the deals with different
things isn't it so I mean YouTube charge
for all sorts so it's just anyway yeah
um
uh I was gonna say
villains so villains has been talking
about anything and oh my God Firefly
starving can both be best
Firefly might be coming back we're going
to be doing a video talking about the uh
you know Firefly return again shortly
um because I've heard a few more bits of
little bits of information about it
exciting so you don't care I want to use
something no I said no way but look at
Jenny's most recent comment y'all both
like that a lot
I did not know that Jenny
and we have to have a conversation about
that young Jenny I didn't even see the
series and I thought it was cool yeah
yeah
um then we will we need to have a little
conversation about that so that would be
very cool uh maybe when Jen comes on if
you will let's have a chat about Firefly
rather than Stargate because I know
there are other channels Jenny's talked
to and it's a little bit complicated but
anyway
um so villains
when Bad Robot pitched this apparently
they did Pitch that and the original
gold raw would return nuclear weapon to
the face but he just shook it off he was
fine
um but
the villain is vital I've always said
the villain in sci-fi is the if you a
good to make a good show great you need
a good villain and Stargate that was one
of the things that was best at just like
we you know it kept Reinventing itself
kept coming up with new villains it kept
you know every every single one was
absolutely you know even those stupid
little robot spiders who think oh
they're gonna hurt anybody even they
were brilliant so um
how important is the villain and do we
need to see something new
I'd like to see something new but if
they were to go with something old I'd
like to see Anubis because it's because
we've said it so many times it's the
only one who would who was defeated that
didn't actually die
so it's the one that makes sense
yeah and noodles and replicators make
sense I think the most and not
necessarily replicators in in
Milky Way galaxy kind of term analogy
probably atlantis's
Nano replicators but I'm only on season
four so I'm working on it I'm on season
four though I'm close I'm getting there
evil feelings
we want evil Ewoks to come back
when I did the video suggesting evil
Ewoks you would not believe the grief I
got the comments
[Laughter]
I don't like this idea that the furlings
are evil
I've never liked it
part of the four Great Races they were
allies they can't be evil I just don't
want them to be but I never said they
would be evil this is what people jump
like I know I know what you mean they
they think they're doing good but they
think they were doing the right thing
yeah or it's a sect of the furlings and
this is why we lost the feelings and
they uh and I my idea was the furlings
created the gold
um or this sect of the Furnace created
the gold world and that was like the
greatest crime because then the rest of
the feelings were peace loving couldn't
revert you know couldn't get rid of the
gold ruled because
um that would be killing it'd be
genocide basically so we're stuck with
him but there's this great evil that was
created in the universe and it was a
sect of the feelings that did it to
control mankind because we were
spreading too quick we was breeding like
crazy
um so that was that was my idea and then
that was an evil that was but so then
they they got banished this sect and it
was the banished feelings that were
returning that was my idea
um and uh but you can do anything with
that I just like the idea of like an
ancient evil return you know but but not
being evil they think they're doing the
right thing they think that's a veneer
the veneer coming back that would be
that would be cool okay
I think that's it I don't think it's too
important initially to have a ridiculous
villain I think you could start off with
just like um something with the gold
because we know the gold is still there
I I think you start off with something
familiar
because there's so much story they've
got to tell there's so much over a
decade has gone by that we've got to get
caught up on yeah so I think don't get
too bogged down you know maybe have
something like that but I loved our
Anubis idea again we're telling them how
to do it but I love darrenu beside it
you've got a sect of gold or something
that are trying to return of trying to
bring Anubis back magnet
I knew this magnet so something to like
bring it because he's in that eternal
battle
um
um and it's something either to kill Oma
or kill all the Ancients except for I
think that would be a cool way as well
because we know the Ancients can be
killed because the or I were so
um The Arc is not the ark
the weapon that Merlin made is
essentially floating around in the aurai
Galaxy at the moment because they sent
it off into the organic someone could
have easily like when it wasn't Like a
Torpedo wasn't it yeah yeah and it was
just waiting to be completed right
but it was completed they said they
finished it and they managed to kill the
aura they killed they killed all of them
and that's why when Adria ascended she
was the most powerful because she
absorbed all of that power because she
wasn't in that Galaxy she was here
wouldn't she yeah or whatever yeah so
that's why the Eternal fire thing but so
all of the Power was into Adrian that's
why she was so powerful in the Arc of
Truth movie
um so when they used the Arc of when
they use the ark and they all stopped
leaving that power was diminished and
then uh what was her name what was her
name uh Morgan Buffet
she's essentially now in the same state
as a noob as Anubis in a Perpetual fight
but so I'm back as well
and Morena Baccarin is great so her
coming back could be cool
she's so pretty
um and I I remember watching um watching
was she in poem Deadpool she was in uh
um what's the Batman Batman
in America what's your agency called
it's not the FBI it's home something
Urban security oh man security she was
in Homeland was his name is Sears
Homeland thank you
um like she was scared of clothes it was
so freaky I remember seeing a Nathan
Fillion talking about it because we've
seen more of Marina than we were
expecting so I think he was joking about
it she was thinking a lot in that series
um but um it was surprising because I
only watched it from Arena
that's called Homeland
um
really short hair in Phoenix
uh but I love Morena Moore and I love
anything if Marina turns up at my door
I'm kicking my wife out of the way and
I'm just running away with it okay
um celebrity hot pass for your wife
she's on one of my lists yeah she's on
my list but also have you ever seen in
interviews she's so cool she's just
she's swear Trooper she swears like a
like a sailor but it's just really cool
she's really funny mine is great so yeah
if they could bring Adria back for the
movie maybe that'd be great
they have to bring Vala back
yeah and that would be fine with me as
well I love Claudia Black she's just
funny I love Claudia Black yeah she was
in she was in something recently
that looked pretty good I can't remember
what it was called it was a series or a
movie
she was in Pitch Black the uh way back
when I had completely forgotten she was
in Pitch Black and I was so happy seeing
her I I showed it to a friend I think
two weeks ago for the first time and I
was like Vala because I was I was in the
Middle season
no she's great and um a book all right
then
we think Daniel Jackson's gonna be
honest because we we're pretty confident
Michael Shanks is coming back
um I I would go as far as I'm 80
confident Michael Shanks the man is
happening coming back for this
um
if they bring Daniel Jackson back do
they bring his wife Vala please yes
please we'd be so happy wouldn't we
to see how much
um
she would have changed because I think
on her own she was very uh well she was
still suffering really and still trying
to get by in the universe after being uh
kotesh is like host for so long but now
she's settled down
what's she like because that would be
really interesting I don't know a lot of
people would probably watched it and be
like Val has changed like yeah well of
course yeah she's going to if you settle
down she's going to change
in that last episode where she aged so
much they were completely different
people yeah completely different but
naturally aged you know as you get as
you grow with another person in your
life you you start to adopt parts of
their personality and they and they're
yours so I'd like to see how much she's
changed and how how much Daniel would
have changed as well because he would
have changed as well oh yeah that would
be really interesting
and they're just funny off of each other
as well and legitimately aren't good off
of each other not just one of my
favorite scenes in Stargate was when and
Vala comes down the Stargate and Ben
Browder and Michael Shanks are stood
next to each other and she said shallow
gene pool and then they just sort of
looked pretty sure they're like because
they look so alike
um
Ben Browder coming back is for me a
given he's still he appeared in the like
um the Guardians of the Galaxy movie
recently he's one of the gold dudes
um he he doesn't age I believe because I
mean this has been a few years now I
mean I've got to remember Richard in
Anderson is not coming back for a big
series 20 episodes but whatever he's
he's 70 something years old even though
he's lost a load of weight did you guys
see him at this Comic-Con not long ago
yeah you posted something he looks good
man I I that would also not straight
there was a room refused that he lost
loads away and it was because basically
um Brad Wright told him
you need to lose some weight mate you're
coming back to Stargate and he wrote we
know he was written in because we knew
we we've seen a few of the um IDs he had
because he was going to be married to
Sam and but they were going to be they
were split up because he said you've
left your toothbrush here and there's a
couple of lines like that
um so
Richardson returning but you know he
might be that Amazon have had a word the
last thing I heard was Richard Anderson
hasn't been approached for this
but
I mean if you were going to do that you
would keep it under your hat wouldn't
you I mean and yeah
I I just think we're going to get a lot
of like little fake news stories I think
in the next next couple of months we're
gonna be really careful with the rumors
in the next couple of months I think
there's going to be a lot of talking
about it now
and which is announcing will be the
center of that book
for me
take a dumper truck full of money drive
it up to Richardson house and just go
take as much as you like
um you know in fact we're Amazon how
many TVs do you want we'll get you as
many TVs as you like and we'll have a TV
in every room do you want a TV in your
toilet brilliant 54 inch TV in your
toilet whatever you want mate just just
please come and do Stargate and I I
think he would I think if they got him
just come and do a movie I think he
would
um that would make the most sense and I
know Matt doesn't want him to die but
he's gonna he's broken kill him he's not
gonna die just let him live in the
universe I don't want to see Jack die
we've seen him die before I mean like
over and over again and he come back yes
I don't want Perma death
I don't want that character to be gone
forever
even if Richard Dean Anderson dies which
obviously he will one day I want to know
in my mind that Jack O'Neill is still
around
his clone is he's closed fine that's not
the same thing Throne is dandy mate come
on dying saving the universe one big
killings
it's like killing the doctor you don't
kill the doctor you don't kill Jack
O'Neill but doesn't the doctor just get
like replaced over and over anyway
but unfortunately Jack is a human and he
can't do that
so don't kill him at the end of the day
what is worse
RDA one last hurray and dies save the
universe they recast him
don't recast him either well that's
what's gonna inevitably happen if they
don't need to recount them you can have
a different character just don't let
that character die
forever mate you know it's not reality
no that's what I'm saying Richie didn't
answer he's gonna die at some point I'm
fully I'm fully prepared for that I
don't know China's likeness to Amazon
for me
I don't want to
hey mate these things happen we there's
lots of things we don't want we didn't
want 12 years without Stargate in our
lives but we wouldn't happen true so
yeah
um
I'd like to say I do think we really do
have to be careful in the next 12 months
about
um
stories and rumors and things so I I'm
always really careful about trying to
make sure we don't I don't share stuff
that's
too unreliable but I'm going to be even
more careful in the next couple of
months because now I think we've gone
with this this trigger's been pulled
there's gonna be a lot of people talking
about it so I mean it's really exciting
but if anybody is going to San Diego
Comic-Con please get in touch because
I'd love people to be over there giving
us information you can as if you send us
a couple of videos from San Diego
Comic-Con that'd be even better if you
can get in the room I am telling you if
we get
Amanda Tapping and Michael Shanks
announced for San Diego Comic-Con
that's how they're going to do it and
that'll be that'll be exciting we should
know about that I don't think there's
been many names released for the
Comic-Con just yet but or confirmed but
yeah that'll be exciting
anyway more importantly they need to do
the idea of the with the Rings
um but more importantly Legally Blonde
three
um
what's the storyline there do we think
because she's already a senator or
something so
RoboCop I'm excited about as well come
on RoboCop yeah yeah I'm pretty excited
about that
um they can't the the the attempt to
reboot a couple of years ago was awful
so I mean what the TV reboot no no they
did a movie and Michael Keaton was in it
Michael Keaton was the only good bit in
it
um
I must have missed that it was Joe
kinnamon the guy that plays Rick Flagg
in like suicide squad and stuff I think
most of it drive his face on show loads
because it kept showing almost like no
keep the visor down oh yeah
um but but apparently this is supposed
to be the sequel we were supposed to get
after the first RoboCop so they made
RoboCop it was really really really
popular so they made RoboCop super sexy
I thought was quite good but they made
it quite quickly but the guy that
actually wrote the first story was um
behovah was writing it's not very good
but the guy that wrote the novel it was
based on was writing the proper Sequel
and it they didn't get time so they
didn't make it
um but this is supposed to be that so
that'll be cool so I'm expecting
massively violent
um just very cool
um
uh you know I'd love to see that so
let's let's see what happens with
RoboCop as well I think that'd be
exciting
and I'd love to see him do something but
this MGM has so many really good
properties it's really good and things
it owns
um I think we're going to be having some
really exciting content in the next few
years
um but but yeah
um oh I love this shows and unpatriotic
it kind of was actually
it was very anti-American
it re or very anti-west not even
anti-American it was anti-west
um or and you know anti-democracy anti
thing it was it kind of was it was
sorry Harris
no I'm just saying it was an odd take
yeah it was just really really really
bad and everything else yeah um next
week we're going to be talking about
Legally Blonde three
for at least three hours
um so um we'll be talking about the
different storylines we'll be talking
about I think I might be busy that day
I'm gonna make you watch the original
I've seen the original it's fine but
like I'm not I don't want to watch it
again I didn't want to watch the second
one like after watching the first
um we can blame Jenny for um that road
recovery
um
he he was he was I actually really like
the actor but even he was great um is
there anything that we've spoken about
tonight that you haven't worked on
the last star Fighters is struggling to
get out of development hell but we might
actually get a sequel to The Last
Starfighter um it's been in the
development they did um there was a
YouTube video sort of like advertising
it about six months ago got the the guys
at show running and trying to get off
the ground it's just getting the money
but that that might actually happen
it'll be the last star five tours and it
will be a direct continuation from the
original movie which is awesome so um
I'd love to see that film and we do have
a Discord server um there should be a
link in the description if I remember to
put the links in the description
I believe there is
I can't remember if I did it or not now
but uh late last night
that is the link for the description for
the Discord dsc.dg forward slash science
what's the GG stand for
good game
oh okay not the dcsc stand for
okay
it's called URL is discord.gg because
it's a platform primarily used for
gamers but now it's been adopted for
just large communities in general but
that's why they've got GG because GG is
what you say when you've when you've
when you've well not so much now but
back in the day you'd do a game you go
GG
you type GG
um if it is a soft reboot I'll turn to
timeline reality like the gate um is
first used today 2024 instead of 1994 ra
could be a villain of the movie ocean
brah if he came from an alternate
reality you mean why not
um all super chats will be read out as
always and we'll discuss them because
that's always interesting so it goes
getting super if there's anything you
want us to demand what insist we talk
about
um
ah Jenny never worked on the last
Starfire we found one
she's not old enough for films she's
it's spring chicken there's no way
um I don't think it was made by um
um
but but yeah oh God my internet's
slowing up so I guess
um
I
okay guys if they brought Raw Back
in like an alternative Universe through
the mirror dimension thing example that
go nuts I I do quite like because
because the girl award aren't a threat
anymore
yeah but I like the idea of it's
starting the new franchise kicking off
with a familiar threat
it feels like full circle sort of thing
yeah I get it I get that but
we we have the Daedalus equipped with
Asgard beams he would appear in his ship
and we'd be like
next
and he'd be gone end of movie
like it's not it's not a good not at
that point that's not a bad point the
gold would have to get some sort of
he would have to be the equivalent of
Anubis from that universe so we need
Anubis back on
y'all made me think a little bit earlier
what if they almost what if the Gould
was words like okay we were always more
technologically advanced and the less
technologically advanced species beat us
by being less technologically advanced
in thinking in a different way more so
than actually like just being strong or
anything like that
what if the Gould because you know we
kind of during sg1 as a species we kind
of help the Unis along a little bit
we're like okay well this unus they're
they're speaking with people now they
can kind of interact with people yada
yada what if they're gold
re went back to the unas because they're
physically stronger and more capable and
a human is typically they might not be
as like maneuverable but what if they
pretended like unises were like
advancing their species but actually
under the guise of Gould and came back
and just tried to knock everybody out
they could even do that while still
trying to get back Anubis and trying to
take out omadasala and all these
different things
could come back but they would have to
severely like up their game
and that's not that's not a bad idea
what you just said with the owners I
think that's pretty that could that
could actually work
but yeah
well look that goes into Joe freaking
robot who we always sort of go whenever
we talk about John freaking robot we
should like
first salt over our shoulder if they get
mentioned or
just go
throwing poop everywhere and but they
did an article saying it's got to be a
hard reboot I think giant freaking robot
I'm possibly watching this channel
because we talked about that a year ago
um so
there is an argument to say that a hard
reboot wouldn't be the terrible idea
right because of all the things we just
mentioned
the Towery are incredibly powerful by
the end of Stargate sg1 yes but we're
also incredibly stupid
oh 100 yeah but I mean we've all got
that we lost the Asgard court within
five minutes of having it we're gonna
lose it again doesn't matter how
advanced we are we didn't lose
[Music]
they literally blew up the ship that the
Asgard Corps was on and the only reason
that we still have it is because teal
went back in time
yeah but we've still got it yes but that
happened they still lost it it will
happen again okay
um but we all right we're chasing them
down when the doorway were tracking it
they were gone now yeah there's no one
hacking it but
it it does make the the reboot and the
return I don't like the little reboot
we're gonna say the return of Stargate
it does make it harder when we're the
baddest Fleet on the thing you know it's
like we're gonna need a villain that
really is the furlings or Anubis or
something like that it's gonna have to
be and the there's always that risk and
it's like we said on this channel over a
year ago we want Stargate we don't want
Star Trek and the thing is with Stargate
it could be happening they can't do that
now
so I've said it before I think through
for a a threat to be threatening it's
going to be it's gonna basically come
down to how big is your army if they
have a bigger Army they're going to be a
threat and I think
because of everything you've just said
about us being super powerful we've got
this technology we probably got a bit
arrogant over the last 10 years we we
have stayed we have just stagnated we're
arrogant that we're top dogs you can't
do anything you can't touch us someone
has been building an army someone will
have been building an army solution
Alliance could be someone who knows and
they'll be like nah sit down it doesn't
matter how powerful your technology is
just look at the Ancients they were the
most powerful beings in in the galaxy
and they got overrun by what the
greatest bug variant Wraith
um and and well you could say that the
gold were the most powerful species when
we think often we got we just turned up
with a bunch of P90s and we defeated
them week after week basically
everything they read more and more
people we had the free Jafar Nation
where more people on our side there was
more of us than there was of them
therefore we won
it's it's it's like the uprising in
Egypt there was more of the Egyptians to
overthrower
the hard reboot argument comes down to
emotion I think a lot of it I don't want
to hard reboot I hate the idea I don't
like the idea of erasing
16 17 series of brilliant television
um you know 16 years whatever it was
running all of that all of those things
that happened I don't want to erase all
that
but if I was making Stargate if I was
Mark Fergus and I was writing this down
now and I was saying I would be there
going I wish I could do a hard reboot
guys this is really hard
you know there are there are problems
with it
um a hard reboot is loads easy the
hybrid route
that's the best option in that sense
look at like shows like Doctor Who
I always go back to the doctor who I
know and it probably annoys everyone but
2005 when Doctor Who come back it was a
reboot but it was a hybrid reboot
everything that had happened before
still happened but it was a reimagining
of what we'd already seen and I think if
they did something like that it would do
quite well yeah
and I think that's that's kind of what I
was told when when we first heard about
Mark Fergus coming on board
what I was told was that there was a
development period in the first well
when I actually first heard that Mark
Ferguson on board he was only on board
to do like a Bible for the series
and the idea was that he was to develop
a Bible and it wasn't necessarily going
to be penguin and Parker they're going
to make it but Amazon wanted a do's and
don'ts the Stargate return and that was
like their first step that Mark Ferg's
developed that
um
and then obviously we found out later
Marco was actually asked for the series
so um that was again that was Jenny
stiven that dropped that honest actually
no he asked for it
um so well we found out that okay the
Bible was just the first step then but
but that wasn't a straight up this is
Canon it was more of a
there's a what can we what can you get
away with and what can't you what is
hard Cannon what can you not touch and
what
could you get away with
um just a quick second I still say I
still say if you want guaranteed success
movie we'll mow it he's got zero for DC
now backup bricks yeah we talked about a
couple of weeks ago 100 movie Jason
Momoa piece of piss so easy so easy to
do and it's a movie that you don't need
to have watched Stargate to enjoy and
that is worth doing so yeah it's a very
good point
should we finish talking about Brad
Wright for two minutes before we
head off
so
um I messaged Brad Wright last week as
as I do from time to time
um and he very graciously
um responds sometimes he always responds
actually through her because he's
Canadian he's very polite so but but
then now he's brilliant so I basically
said look now is this has been announced
as good as
um the fans want Brad we want Brad to be
involved that's fair to say
um and I said look I I don't want to do
anything
um without your sort of say so so I I
would love to talk about getting Brad
right right I'd love to you know like
promote any campaign that would be
interested but
um I don't want to make you feel awkward
I don't want to do anything so you know
if you if you'd rather I didn't just
stay safe he basically come back and
said look I'm not getting a phone call
from Amazon I'm not I just hope they do
something brilliant with Stargate I'm
really proud that it's coming back I've
got other stuff I'm working on that I'm
trying to get off the ground
um but but you know but but thank you so
much sort of thing so I took that as a
polite
don't worry about it
um
what do you guys think though about
if Brad comes back
is the project safer simple as that
however whatever you think about Market
Vegas however success you know however
good his job he is
is it safer with Brad I'm on board in
some form
I think it would be steered in a more in
the right direction with Brad involved
even if it was just a like a consultant
or something
Marcus Mark Focus has done this Bible
yeah he's probably done a lot of
research into it but he didn't create
the show if they had some sort of input
from Brad they'd be able to steer the
ship in in more of the the direction
that it was already heading in rather
than
just looking at the map and going in
whichever way you think is North yeah
yeah
I mean it doesn't matter really how well
Mark Fergus knows the series and it does
seem to again I've I've heard a couple
of rumors now that
um he really knows Stargate backwards is
he's not just a fan he's a he's a good
I'm confident that Mark ferbers will do
a good job I am confident but I think
you can always do better you can no
one's perfect
like you can be the you can be really
good at your job but with the help from
others you can be better and we just
want the best the best Stargate possible
Brad being involved in some capacity I
think will achieve that I think I think
everyone that's how everyone feels but
yeah Brad's just like this if there is a
singular mind behind Stargate in general
it's Brad and to have that mind on board
just even if it's not the singular
focused mind to like push the series
forward if it's a Consulting mind or if
it's just a an extra producer on there
anything of the sort just
it makes us happier it feels a little
more homely for the series
I think so I think so and I just think
is that like I said as a consultant
somebody's come on through ideas around
even if he's not necessarily in charge I
necessarily have to be on payroll like
I've got a consistent person on payroll
all he needs is to have one meeting with
with uh mark
and Hawk they just have a meeting they
sit down together and they go these are
my ideas what do you think and he can be
like Yep this is this is what we
originally had planned
um that works well so you could you
could do this you could do that you
could do that and they could split ball
ideas together and then you they can
kind of get to know how his mind was was
working at that point and then adapt to
that mindset
do you know one idea that I would go for
and really easily as well is you get
Brad's original script for a story and
you make a version of that if as close
as you can because then you can
basically advertise this saying
um Brad was involved in this yeah the
fans of gators would go crazy for that
we'd be like we're still going to get to
see Brad's or at least a version of
Brad's original what he wanted to have
you know and at very least get Brad
Wright's stamp of approval on it do not
mean it's like you need him to come out
and say like yeah we've had meetings
with talk to Brad he shared some ideas
with us Brad white remembrance tried to
do that with Roland Emerick he tried to
get roller Denmark to sort of talk to
him and and they weren't interested
they're saying look you do you we like
the T we like the movie you do you and I
think that's probably a good thing in
the long run well just thinking about
that oh uh I can't see who
oh C3 Panther pickle made the comment
but
does Brad even want to come back without
being in charge necessarily I'm sure
he'd want to have some kind of say with
Stargate in general but that is his baby
and if there is a singular mind for
Stargate it's Brad so does he have any
interest coming back at Atlantis oh he
gave that to malosi so I don't think
he'd necessarily want to be
maybe he would maybe you would want to
show on it again but I think I think
he'd want to let's be honest he'd want
to yeah yeah yeah
I think it'd be okay if he at least had
a meeting with Mark and Hawk got to meet
them got to see what their ideas were
and yeah and if they decided to then use
like his screen
so they they could use it Anyway Amazon
could you say yeah use his script
here's Brad script rewrite that for a
movie crack on yeah yeah
well if
I I I'm just bitballing ideas again if
he does come back and is willing to come
back as a consultant a producer kind of
deal
do you think that would open the door
for him to
Show run a spin-off series or to do his
own movie based off of something or do a
do a straight to streaming movie based
upon the series that comes out something
of the sort and again the funds that go
crazy I mean they were no crazy good
advertising I think for just everything
in general yeah come and direct a couple
of episodes yeah
it's just again easy it's an easy win in
it just you just get a couple episodes
um
speak into Brad like I say I'm not I
don't want to speak for Brad but
everything I get sent and I've watched
loads of interviews with him over the
years and things like this and I've
spoken to him a little bit about this
just through tweets not you know nothing
nothing
not loads but my sense is that he would
quite happily come back and he would do
whatever they asked him to do because he
loves Stargate and I don't think he's
got he's not one of those guys in
Hollywood that's got a massive ego but
he would be like I'm in charge or
nothing it's my Stargate well I think it
seems to me that he's really proud that
stargate's a project that he worked on
he didn't create it he was involved he
got the movie and he reworked it for
television so it's not like he he
invented he wrote the original story or
anything but it was a project that he
always says it's something brilliant
that I worked on and we don't feel like
that do we we feel like no man you were
Stargate
now something I worked on I worked on
for a long time I absolutely love it I'm
really proud it's coming back
um I just think
Amazon are missing a trick there the the
amount of crap Amazon got over Lord of
the Rings
I just thought they'd learn their lesson
and it's not that
he wouldn't come back because he would
in a heartbeat
well and it was already coming back
before before Amazon bought MGM he was
already coming back they were already in
talks and then they just ghosted him
yep and that's the thing Amazon just
doesn't need to ghost people because
look at Peter Jackson and Warner
Brothers right now
they're Peter Jackson got ghosted by
Amazon and now he's in charge of
everything they're doing over there
instead of somehow Bridging the Gap
anywhere you know uh he's he's now got
his own Lord of the Rings and
I don't think that would happen with
Stargate per se I don't think there's
like rights to go hand out to other
people or other Studios either but
don't ghost the guy don't ghost the guy
that's been
the singular mind if there is one you
know it's just I'll tell you what though
I think I suspect and again I don't know
but I suspect if Brad Wright thought he
was being used just to put a name on it
um and he didn't actually have
he wasn't actually allowed to contribute
but they wanted to slap his name on it
to calm Gators down I don't think he'd
go for that I think he'd probably tell
him to shove it
is well politely because he's Canadian
shove it here yeah
um but um you would I don't think
um
I think and Jenny Simon's is bang on
there I don't think that the whole thing
between
Lord of the Rings and Amazon was more
complicated than they just ghosted him
apparently there was deals with Warner
Brothers etc etc and it was it was more
complicated than that but um I think
they never did the decency of saying it
is more complicated they did just kind
of ghost him after that because they
could have just been like hey we can't
talk to you legally and instead they
just kind of they just left him out
there which would suck you know uh
especially being that involved with
something like that
I know what he's doing
right guys we will call that a day now
because I don't know what you guys I'm
getting a sore throat
um there's only so much talking we can
do even though I could really really
talk about Stargate all freaking day and
we will
um the plan's basically going to be now
when we do lives um each week you know I
do the catch up hello hi Mama wanted to
say hi real quick it's Mama Harris I
enjoy watching y'all she is knows
nothing about Stargate yeah I don't
really know anything but I enjoyed
listening yeah and we love your son we
put up with him every single week yeah
we're good that gives me a break every
now and then it's absolutely great thank
you for having him uh we love him we
love him thank you yeah your mama's
sweet she's fine horrible Sweden really
the right word watch out there's
microphone's loud
accent gotta love it
um but yeah so what we're going to do is
instead of me doing a video on sides
each week I think we're going to start
each live video and we're going to have
a little Stargate moment at the start of
Our Lives now on a Sunday and so we will
any updates I've got we will drop we
will talk about anything that's that's
happened in the week we'll get our
opinions on it
um and so every week we'll start with
Stargate corner or whatever we're going
to call it
um so we'll we'll keep doing that and
when there's nothing to talk about we'll
just talk about what the hell we want to
talk about so circle of Stargate yeah I
don't know if Matt liked Stargate corner
from their facial expressions
[Laughter]
um I I just popped into my head I don't
know why I said that but you know what I
mean we'll have a little still guys
don't have corners yeah it's right
Stargate circumference
um or something radius the Stargate
radius oh man it might be called the
Stargate radius
um I'll get pie yeah whatever that
actually uh what's that one YouTube
channel it's nerd cookies you could have
a Stargate pie kind of version of it I
like nerd cookies they're really good I
love their little intro yeah I'm like
right the briefing room I might just go
like do seven seven Chevron so we'll
start the briefing room that's a great
idea that's good briefing room Stargate
The Briefing room something like that
Sci-Fi TV movie channel and this is the
briefing room and we can have our own
little like door opening intro I'm not
going to make that that I'm not gonna
don't make that
Horizon is good the orifice cook
laughs
it's so rude yes they are refreshed
Circle Alexander one more with the word
orifice written on it and she becomes
obsessed
um but there guys thank you so much but
hey look the main thing is this week
we've had what I think is the first
virtually official announcement they're
actually getting this I think we've
known for a while now Stargate was going
to happen
now we know it's gonna happen and that's
the that's the really really cool thing
so
it's a great week
um bigger bada boom
um yes if deadline variety or The
Hollywood Reporter report it
um it's just now when
um but as I said guys anybody that is
going to San Diego Comic-Con or if you
know somebody that's going to stand here
in Comic-Con I very much want to hear
from them that email is side.trek1
gmail.com or you can go to the Facebook
group it's Jamie rixson
DM me
um I would very much like to talk to you
if you're going to the San Diego Comic
Con because I don't think I'm going to
be able to get tickets
um even though I was invited to like a
Comic Con in Milwaukee
uh and they said we would love you to
come in like be on a panel and I was
like that's I'm very reflected that's
great how much are you paying me to do
this yeah Supply sandwiches I guess I
can't go to Milwaukee
come as a very expensive sandwich I mean
I I'm very very flattered and I would
love to do anything like that I would I
might be a dream to do like a panel and
like a Comic-Con or something that'd be
amazing
um tell me if he's a plane ticket and a
sandwich
yeah yeah I need a plane ticket a hotel
room and yeah there's more than one
sandwich
are you going to be specific about your
sandwich what was that breakfast
sandwich you made again with your
Canadian bacon ham whatever it was oh
man it was it's not Canadian Banks it's
bacon
um fat bacon sausages but it's the bun
it's how you do the egg is that's the
secret bit you gotta dip the bun in the
egg and then fry it so it's a bit like
French toast and it's amazing it's the
best bacon sandwich but um guys thank
you
it's 10 20 10 30. no it's it's noon it's
I got different watches on different
times oops
[Music]
I don't know what time it is anymore
I would also love it guys while you
think I'm gonna do a little series
um just like
um a funny you know like having a joke
um I'm gonna do I'm gonna play a
character I've never done this before
but I'm gonna give it a go
um and I'm gonna be the um Stargate
health and safety advisor
right unless you can do a series of
videos just like getting more and more
stressed about all the ridiculous health
and safety stuff goes on so if you've
got any ideas from Stargate that you
think would drive a health and safety
advice a crazy
um again drop us a message let us know
and I'll um try to work it into my bit
and we'll see how it goes you may never
actually see this because I might do it
and it might be so bad I just can't show
it to anybody but I'm gonna give it a go
so
um also let Jay know if you want him the
paperwork when Jack O'Neil
Dan good near that black hole it was
never ending no no I just like okay do
you know how hard it is to write a um
risk assessment for a man that keeps
sticking his head in alien technology
every other bloody week
I just think there's a lot of silliness
there but it's going to be like part of
the uh
civilian oversight I think I'm going to
that's right that's going to be a joke
yeah exactly so
um what were you gonna say Harris anyway
before Matthew I was gonna say everybody
let Jay know if you want him to do a
Stargate cosplay calendar too you know
Jesus Christ nobody needs to see that
nobody needs to see that man
no business I'm I'm carrying a couple of
stone that don't nobody needs to see
okay well then then let Matt know if he
needs to do it
yeah
you might not be that's the first thing
I I think I'm definitely heavier than
you
I've got quite impressive moves but um
[Music]
[Laughter]
Stargate Calendar please no
um there were cables everywhere that's
one thing I've already noticed Charles
cables everywhere it's a where are the
cable ties come on people
our gate future
thanks guys like it's been a big week
we're very excited as you can tell and
we've had Jenny stiven on live which is
amazing thank you so much Jen your your
contribution I know she's been getting
in the comments and telling people you
know everything she knows and which is
absolutely amazing hopefully United one
two nil
hold on oh yeah bring it over at least
once didn't it
um I didn't notice I wonder who scored
Diego de low at least they're not losing
the seven to zero or zero to seven now
that was bad we're third in the league
um do you guys know how much I love this
channel the United keep playing on a
bloody Sunday at R4 and I still turn up
you're welcome
and she's like
but are you really here
yes I am really here but are you
every now and then it's you know United
you just like phase out of existence and
you go into football land deep fake Jay
over here
glitches
sorry
um yeah no that's okay but guys um thank
you so much say bye bye we're out of
here
hello
see you later guys see you next week
[Music]
foreign